welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and praise moon jesus because moon
night is finally here everybody showing
all of us impatient lovers of moonlight
justice just how hard the fists of
conscious fly this video is brought to
you by squarespace they're the
all-in-one platform to build a really
cool website and run your business that
bathroom sink did not stand a chance
like that thing shattered like the bones
of an invisible egyptian jackal who just
messed up the wrong moon themed
mercenary who also works at a gift shop
and calls his non-moon-themed mom to
chat on a regular basis because he's a
good son or is he tamayo because if it's
already common knowledge that the
physical body of the moon knight hero
was originally solo hosted by mark
spector because he was born as mark
spector with his own real biological mom
spectre then who the hell is steven
grant calling mommy on the phone to hm
if i have to call somebody mommy on the
phone i have to pay several thousand
dollars an hour it better not be on may
because i don't think my virgin ears can
take all of that again so let's dive
into this moon themed mommy mystery
together by nerd babies because the
possibilities are kind of wild
considering how it's pretty much
impossible for the steve graham
personality to have a biological mother
the most obvious answer to me as to who
steve is talking to on the phone is of
course mark spector the man in the
mirror himself as we can see from moon 9
episode 1 uh steve definitely has some
slight sleepwalking issues very much
implying that mark specter steve grant's
other self retakes control over his
biological physical body once the
maidenless gift shop grants goes good
night and my god is that man maidenless
after this episode but here's the thing
y'all if this is mark spector's body and
this steven grant guy is just borrowing
it to squander it being some type of
dripless egypt nerd at the london
national art gallery then mark needs to
keep tabs on what the hell the steve
grant guy is even doing because this
dude seems like a noodle head as we can
clearly see from this episode when steve
grant blacks out and loses control over
his body to the mark side of the force
he straight up does not remember any
mercenary brand murders that mark
commits so the opposite might just be
true from mark spector's perspective
because think about it in the comics
mark spector is a mercenary with a ton
of military training like this dude is
one of the best in the world as
evidenced by the trail of dead bodies
will no longer be waking up to go go
anywhere anytime soon but that being
said if there's one thing a man with
military experience is it's prepared so
if this steve grant persona is truly the
parasite that khonshu says he is in
mark's body then mark is going to have
to prepare himself for when steve
eventually and inevitably takes over his
body which means literally tricking
steve into believing that he's leaving
voicemails to his dear old mama grant on
holiday when he's actually just giving
mark all of the intel that mark needs to
know about the comings and goings of his
handsome oscar isaac body especially if
the steve guy is dead set on leaving
traps around the house like steve could
literally be telling mama mark all of
his sleepwalking problems and the
measures that he's taking to track them
which could explain why steve keeps
waking up securely shackled with his
door tape and bed sand undisturbed
despite very clearly having gotten out
of bed that night steve is snitching on
himself with mark spectre possibly even
leaving steven grant postcards from all
the places that mark spectre visits on
his many moon night missions places like
madrid spain which is the postcard that
stephen graham puts on his fish tank at
the beginning of the episode as we can
see the statue of a bull fighter that
resides outside the plaza de toros de
las ventas in madrid on the postcard
places like madrid spain the gondolas of
what appears to be venice italy and
somewhere in the northern hemisphere
where the northern lights are visible
the aurora borealis possibly this little
village on the bavarian alps in germany
that steve suddenly and painfully
regains his consciousness in which is
mighty suspicious considering that red
skull's castle where he literally turned
himself into red skull is located in the
bavarian alps as well also his entire
scientific facility from captain america
won the castle the crack from what if
you know where the red skull was
literally trying to summon a god from
another dimension that dude was
literally just traveling all over the
world looking for weird magic stuff
which could be what leads arthur
harrow's own cult back to red skull's
neck of the woods in the show look 2022
is the year we finally got moon night
but if 2022 is the year you finally
start your own business squarespace is
the all-in-one platform to build a
beautiful online presence for that
business the kind of website that looks
great works great and makes you money
squarespace has a bunch of great
features to help your business be
successful you can present members only
gated content create email campaigns or
add online booking for appointments or
sessions all from the squarespace
interface it's really intuitive the
squarespace video studio even helps you
make pro level video content and they
also have great analytics to help you
figure out what's working and what's not
because that promotion you ran where you
carved your url into the stalls of
public restrooms didn't work out as well
as you thought it would just live and
learn live and learn use squarespace
instead so head to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com new
rockstars to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain that's
squarespace.com new rockstars for 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain thanks again to squarespace for
sponsoring this video thank you you're
the best but anyways these postcards
might just be clues from mark spector
that steven grant may have to piece
together throughout the course of the
series possibly after he finds out that
his mother was just one big mom catfish
from mark to track steven's whereabouts
using the postcards to reverse track
mark's whereabouts as moon knight but
that's just mark okay because i don't
think mark is the only suspect here oh
no no no because while mark is likely to
be the one that steven is talking to in
my opinion there is also an absolutely
wild possibility that we need to discuss
the possibility that stephen's mother is
the goddess amit herself i know crazy
but i just find it funny how steve
always seems to sign off his phone calls
to his mom with the words late as gators
love you
later gators when the goddess ahmed
herself has the head of a crocodile and
yes while a crocodile isn't exactly an
alligator like loki the two animals are
very much inextricably linked due to
their visual similarities and do not
forget that we also get this image of a
crocodile and or alligator on a phone in
early moon night trailers as well so
there seems to be some type of implied
symbolic connection between crocodiles
alligators and communication with the
human brain here and by the way that
arthur harrow is talking in episode one
it seems that arthur harrell's life's
work might surround the potential return
of this goddess ahmet into the world of
man after being betrayed by her fellow
gods and apparently her own human avatar
and while we don't particularly know
where exactly ahmet is yet or who her
past avatar was we do know from harrow
as well as from steve's own freaky
experiences with konshu that it is
common for gods to communicate to their
avatar via a disembodied voice so
therefore there is a chance that we
could be looking at a scenario where the
personality of steve grant could
actually be that of ahmet's former
avatar whose mind now resides within
mark spector's brain like a parasite as
conscious lovingly puts it and if steve
grant is actually secretly amit's avatar
who doesn't remember that he's amit's
avatar referring to ahmet as mom would
be symbolically appropriate as that
crocodile goddess would technically be
the hbic in this situation for sure but
that is who i believe steve grant is
talking to on a cellular device but what
do you guys think let us know in the
comment section below my nerd babies
because we got to speculate together
thank you guys so much for watching this
video you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter if you want to
see me tweet some weird [ __ ] you can
follow new rockstars wherever we are on
social media and when you do make sure
you hit that notification bell on
youtube and also please hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com because we have an
amazing line of moon night shirts and
hoodies over there they're freaking
awesome and dope you should go check
them out immediately they literally sell
out so fast so please do yourself a
favor head on over to new rocksmurch.com
pick them up asap and thank you for
spending time with me and i'll see you
guys next time
goodbye
[Music]
you
[Music]